hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast scaling cell therapy
manufacturing presented by Jim Beltzer
PhD we are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
laberd's and sponsored by Tomo BCT true
mo BCT is a global leader in blood
component therapeutic a phoresis and
cellular technologies it is the only
company with unique combination of a
phoresis collections manual and
automated whole blood processing and
pathogen reduction technologies to rumo
BCT believes in the potential of blood
to do even more for patients than it
does today
this belief inspires the company's
innovation and strengthens its
collaboration with customers to learn
more about two-room o BCT please visit
[Music]
www.opm.gov/life herbs and i'm your
moderator for today's event
this webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credits please
click on the CD button at the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
receive your credits before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on the screen and we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you'll be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
and finally if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know you're having
a problem thank you now I'd like to
introduce dr. belt Sura prior to joining
the cell processing team at Jerome
obesity dr. belt who served as lead
scientist for the Rd of Corning
synthamax a synthetic growth surface for
the culture of human embryonic stem
cells at corning life sciences he was a
co-founder of red corporation and was a
key player in the industrialization of
several technology platforms including
stage display and yeast
hybrid he has more than 20 years of
industrial research and development
experience in a broad range of
disciplines please join me in welcoming
dr. belt sir I will now turn the
presentation over to him
today I'd like to present three case
studies in cell therapy manufacturing t
cell expansion case study viral vector
production case study and finally
producing a 10 quantum system watch
before I get to that I would like to
introduce you to the quantum cell
expansion system the quantum is a novel
hollow fiber bioreactor system that is
closed uses continuous perfusion and as
a single use system it's primarily
designed for adherence cells but we also
have some results growing Suspension
cells in the quantum we have automated
all of the necessary steps for
traditional cell culture and we have
extremely good control over the gas
exchange and the temperature in the
quantum this is the single used part
this is the awesome disposable and you
can see the bioreactor on the right and
then the tubing organizer is how the
plumbing interacts with the pumps and
valves on the console system and then to
the left of the screen you can see a
couple of the bags that are attached to
harvest a and the waste bag so here we
have the quantum system with that
disposable mounted so you can see the
hollow fiber bioreactor in the middle of
your screen you can see the four pumps
to control the fluid input to the system
and the circulation of the fluid in the
system also on the Left we have the gas
Inlet and the gas transfer module which
is responsible for all of the gas
exchange that takes place in the quantum
system so where the rubber hits the road
is the hollow fiber bioreactor it's
composed of about 11,500 semipermeable
hollow fibers and you can think of those
very small straws the equivalent surface
area is about 120 T 175 flaps and the
cells grow on the inside of those hollow
fibers as shown in the micrograph that's
on the top right of the screen so there
are basically two different fluid paths
within the hollow fiber bioreactor the
icy loop which runs down the center of
those straws of the hollow fiber and
basically passes straight from left to
right through the center of the
bioreactor and then there's the extra
capillary loop and you can see the inlet
and outlet effect sticking up on the top
of the bioreactor and that's basically
the bath water that fills with space
that surrounds the tall fibers and so
there we can achieve perfusion feeding
of the cells we can use both of these
loops to our advantage so I show here a
hydraulic layout system for the quantum
with the icy loop and the EC loop shown
in red and blue and the hollow fiber
bioreactor shown in the middle so these
controls of Inlet and circulation pumps
will become very important so with the
door closed the bioreactor is now an
incubator in fact we call it a cleanroom
in a box all of the controls are
accomplished through the automated touch
screen on the front of the machine you
can see running across the top the
inlets and outlets are described and
that's one thing the quantum is not
smart enough to know which bag you've
attached to which inlet line so you have
to call that out you also have control
of the various Inlet pumps on the yellow
or for the icy side and in the blue or
for the EC side and you can see the
bioreactor in the middle of your screen
now our engineers have gone to a lot of
trouble to describe a number of
predefined tasks and multi-step tasks so
they're either single step or multi step
these describe to the best of our
ability all the necessary tasks that you
need to perform to culture cells in the
bioreactor but the most important part
of this entire slide is the purple
button that fits above each task
description and that's the modify button
so all these tasks are not viable to
meet your cell culture needs in fact you
can create custom tasks and link them
together to describe even as much as
your entire run in a single custom step
we track the growth of our cells by
family media most commonly from the EC
port there's a lure lock port that's
shown on the left but if you need to get
a sample of the contents of the IC coil
right so that's the IC loop that the
cells are growing on in that loop you
can weld off a portion of the sample
coil as shown in the right before I go
into the case studies I'd like to
introduce a card T cell therapy
manufacturing that's in development at
room o so the basic process is an April
read this product is can be purified
into lymphocytes and then those
lymphocytes are either gene modified and
then activated and expanded finally the
expanded cells are concentrated and
washed and eventually infused into the
patient's this can be accomplished using
two remote devices so the Spector op dia
can do you a phoresis product and
lymphocytes can be purified using the
Eleuthera cell separation system so I'd
like to concentrate on two aspects of
this process that utilize the quantum
system
the first is activation and expansion of
t-cells in the in the quantum system and
the second is the production of viral
vectors using the quantum system as well
so let's start with t-cell expansion in
the quantum system so this is our basic
cell expansion of t-cells in the quantum
system and we typically start out with
2.5 mils of a Luka phoresis product or
25 mils of a looot reiated product and
you can get those either from the
apheresis or from the lucra machine we
loaded 100 million lymphocytes into the
Machine approximately two hundred and
twenty eight million excuse me of those
cells were CD 3 plus T cells those cells
were activated with CD 3 cd28 dynabeads
in a two-to-one ratio of cells to B and
then fed by continuous perfusion so
that's on D 0 on day 3 6 & 9 we
introduce a bolus of il-2 and aisle 7 as
you can see on the timeline and there's
a minimal amount of circulation in the I
feet loop where the cells are of 1 mil
per minute so that's really quite slow
and our gas exchange is taken care of by
the circulating the EC loop at a hundred
mils per minute that's also clearing out
any waste products that may have been
produced by the expansion of themselves
after day six we do flip the bioreactor
once a day just to break apart the
clumps finally on day 12 we harvest the
cells and we were able to harvest after
a twelfth day extension about 15 billion
ki cells
greater than five hundred fold expansion
in 12 days and in a low harvest item of
0.5 to 1 liter now I've shown this same
data in a different format here so you
can see on day 0 we started out with 28
million CD 3 plus T cells and then in
the blue bar in the last column we end
up with 15 billion CD 3 plus T cells
also of interest is that we get a
selective enrichment of the cd8 cells
that shows up quite nicely in day 9 and
day 12 if we look at the flow results
you can see that we end up with a 99%
pure T cell population and that's also a
preferential expansion of our cd8 cells
as I mentioned before coming up to about
69% in the final product there is a
significant drop in the PD 1 expression
and our T cells are expressing il-2 and
interferon gamma the activation markers
so just in summary then we had over a
five hundred fold expansion of to e plus
CD 3 plus T cells over 12 days
no pre-processing a closed system
automated reduces labor it can be used
in a controlled space perfusion fed and
we use a low amount of media in the
process and we have a low volume for our
harvest moving on to viral vector
production in the quantum system so
many of you are familiar with growing
incubators full of flasks or sells
stocks or roller bottles in order to
collect your viral vector supernatant
and I've heard stories of up to 16 10
stacks going into a single prep so this
is a labor-intensive process many open
steps there's a cleanroom is required
because you've got high concentration of
virus large volumes of vector and it's
very contamination prone there are two
types of virus expression they're stable
and transient expression of viral
vectors stable transfection of retro
viral vectors is usually done using a
packaging cell line and your gene of
interest is introduced into a packaging
cell for those purposes transient
expression on the other hand involves
introducing all of the genes required to
produce the virus including the envelope
the gag and the paul-jean so you would
introduce a mixture of four plasmids
into the transient transfection mix both
the packaging cell line in the transient
expression systems has their pros and
cons so the packaging cell line is
obviously very convenient and allows for
stable expression for weeks but that
initial construction of the cell line
can be difficult transient expression on
the other hand is stable for 40 to 72
hours and it is fast and achieves
comparable titers the cons is that's
that's variability and difficult to
scale both of these protocols have been
used on the quantum system here's a
cartoon of our transient expression
experiments to produce lentiviral
vectors in the quantum
and this was done in collaboration with
Gerhardt Bauer's lab at UC Davis or gen
Medicine Center so the first is to load
your HK 293 t-cell if you're in a hurry
and you want to start the next day then
you would load up at least a billion
cells into the bioreactor if you wish to
let the cells expand first in the
bioreactor you can load fewer cells and
allow them to expand so cells are loaded
and allowed to attach to the bioreactor
for 15 hours or overnight and then when
the population of cells has filled the
bioreactor to approximately 1 to 1.5
billion cells then you can begin your
transfection and so that's day one of
the process so the transection you add
the four plasmid as I spoke just spoke
about for the transient expression of
lentivirus in calcium phosphate and you
allow the transactions to proceed for 15
hours in the quantum and then at the end
of that 15 hours you wash out and do an
induction for another 9 hours so at the
end of that time we want to collect the
virus this is on day four and we wanted
to be able to concentrate the virus
afterwards so there was a switch to
serum free media and we then proceeded
to feed the cells for 40 hours during
that time we continuously collected the
viral vector in the supernatant or the
conditioned media that passed over the
cells on day 5 we harvested the cells we
got back our 1 to 2.5 billion to 93 T
cells we were able to tighter and
concentrate the virus particles and
determine the mo AI and the T use per
mil so we've shown that the quantum
system can be used to produce retroviral
and Lenti viral vectors it's automated
it's capable of achieving both stable
and transient expression system
it's a closed system the vector
concentration is equal to what we see in
Flast based systems and using
engineering controls we can control the
volume of the vector containing
supernatant and in the next slide I show
the hydraulic system layout again to
show you how important that is in
concentrating and decreasing the volume
of our virus containing supernatant so
basically that's achieved by harvesting
the IC loop so you can see in the
diagram that we harvest the IC loop into
a separate bag from the EC loop where we
accomplish the feeding of the cells and
so in summary the results of our viral
vector production in the quantum for the
lentivirus we got about 2 times 10 to
the 8th viral particles per mil which
was a similar yield to what's normally
obtained in the cell stack
likewise scan a retrovirus gave similar
results at youth as to what they had
been getting in their plastic base
system and there will be references for
both of these results at the end of the
talk and moving on to the allergen aook
model which is a case study in scaling
out the quantum system from one machine
to ten machines so this case study was a
collaboration between a thesis and its
European subsidiary Regenesis and the
contract manufacturing organization of
master cell so the object was to
transfer the process of so growing map
C's in the quantum to scale that process
out from one machine to ten machines to
create a larger lot size and then
finally to see if there are any
efficiencies that could be gained and
cutting straight to the chase we found
that there was a 40% cost a 40%
reduction in the cost of goods producing
cells in this way so in the first slide
we show the technology transfer a time
line
through to scale out so the first few
weeks were spent simply learning how to
run the quantum and then another six
weeks were used for process optimization
most of this work was on downstream
processing of the cell product and
finally the ten quantum runs were done
in the scale out so this is a comparison
of running a single quantum system here
in the box on the bottom it tells you
how many people are required so you can
see on day one we take two operators to
run the quantum system that's mostly to
prepare the cells and the quantum for
loading with the ten quantum system you
see at the box at the top that two
operators are also required in day zero
and day one or day minus one and day
zero but basically the intermediate
steps can be handled by a single
operator and as I said before the
harvest day is the most difficult and
here we needed more help so finally if
you look at the product that we got you
can see that the flow cytometry profiles
from the comparing the quantum produced
cells to the self stack produce cells
are equal and same the same is true for
the protein secretion so you can see
that we were able to develop a process
that can yield consistent cell qualify
quality and yield and can simplify the
progression from learning to production
and importantly there's a 40% cost
reduction in cost of goods and we were
able to produce large lots of cells so
here are the references for the
lentiviral the retroviral and finally
the scale out of the quantum cell
expansion system thank you very much
Thank You dr. Zeltzer for that
informative presentation it is time for
Q&A if you have a question you'd like to
ask dr. belt sir please do so now just
click on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box it
appears on your screen and click on the
send button well answer as many of your
questions as we have time for let's get
started our first question is can you
control the shear stress in the quantum
for the growth of endothelial cells
thanks for that question first of all
there's very little cheer stress in the
quantum system that's pure physics if
you've got a quarter inch Inlet line
going into the icy loop and a two inch
in diameter bioreactor there's very
little shear that happens having said
that though we can control the flow rate
of the media through the icy loop with
our pumps and if needed we can even feed
across the membrane without creating
shear stress how can I monitor the
growth of the cells in the quantum so
you can monitor the growth in the in the
quantum by taking a sample from the EEC
sample port so that's a lower lock port
that is sterile so there's a point two
micron filter behind it we recommend
that you monitor the lactate production
and glucose consumption and typically
those measurements are done once every
24 hours has the quant have been used to
culture IPS cells yes the quantum has
been used to successfully expand IPS
cells we haven't done differentiation of
IPS cells yet in the quantum but that's
ongoing in fact a recent experiments
have shown that the quantum can
significantly reduce the media required
to expand IPS cells what is the media
perfusion rate in the quantum well the
media perfusion rate typically starts
out at zero or very low so it's at one
point one mil per minute
in the beginning stages of a typical
expansion and it may go as high as one
point six mils per minute at the end of
the typical MSC expansion for viral
vectors and and other applications we
may have to go higher as the cell
densities increase within the quantum so
for the viral vector case we are running
up around 2.5 million it is there a
reason for switching to serum free media
for viral vector production ah yes so
that's a good question if you produce
your viral vectors in serum containing
media it complicates the concentration
of that virus product after you have
finished your run so the serum proteins
would quickly clog the membrane
concentrators that are typically used to
concentrate viral vectors how are the
dynabeads loaded into the system for T
cell expansions very simple we basically
mix the dynabeads with the cells in a
cell inlet bag prior prior to loading
the self into the bioreactor and as I
mentioned yeah the ratio is 2 to 1 what
kind of media is used for T cell
expansions today we tried both Tex Max
and rpm I plus 2% human a B serum and
right now we get the best results with
our PMI but we plan to test more media
in the future so stay tuned we're almost
out of time so this will have to be our
last question how our suspension cells
kept in the hollow fiber bioreactor so
our pumps the circulation pumps in the
quantum expect cell expansion system can
be reversed so we can run those pumps in
such a fashion as to push any cell that
may have gotten out into the rest of the
IC loop back into the bioreactor so
again we just use our circulation pumps
I would like to once again thank
Beltzer for his presentation do you have
any final comments I just want to thank
everybody and if you have any questions
further to this please contact me at my
email that should be on the last slide
of the presentation well thank you once
again I would also like to thank our
sponsor to room o BCT for making today's
educational webcast possible this
webinar has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
CDE button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credits and before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through November 31st 2017 you'll
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye